foreign
[Music]
hey everyone this is my cousin's sister
Sam she's from L.A staying with me now
nice to meet you I'm Melissa captain of
the price team let's take it from the
top Break Every Chain
she writes songs the chorus is the
strongest part if we lose the rest and
type the Loose Ends it could be really
special lose the rest
every team has their Lane and our lane
is real church music how about you learn
an actual gospel song first
times the only thing Atlanta has gone
for it okay we're about to go up and
they're about to meet him it's about to
be great I would like to thank my cousin
Jess for being my ride or die in Atlanta
when my dad
was out there and I didn't want to go
out there it's family business we
outside oh God he sees us
your voice is nice why don't you come
down to the studio
you should sing this song at that church
thing
[Music]
I changed the music
could be great we are
terrible I don't really have a
relationship with God God use fish
donkeys even hoes to get his word across
what's going on I think she's
straight to hell as some people have
said oh church girl got a problem out
there
[Applause]
so y'all really think God's gonna waste
a miracle on y'all this year huh shall I
heard that clap back all the way over
here let's get our praise on
praise songs hit people's heart a little
different Hands-On
[Applause]
[Music]
can I get an amen amen